empiece por favor por explicarnos qué
tan realista es el plan de la unión
europea de no importar más petróleo
desde rusia de aquí a un año teniendo en
cuenta que ese país provee cerca del 30
por ciento del crudo que se consume en
el bloque
el rock es muy realista yo creo que en
el fondo se están tomando todos los
pasos está una decisión que puede
haberse tomado al principio de la guerra
pero países importantes como alemania
necesitaban en re condicionar la
logística porque ellos dependen de
suministros de rusia que vienen por
oleoductos por lo tanto no tienen la
estructura para recibir petróleo por
terminales tuvieron que llegar a
acuerdos con polonia para hacerlo una
vez que alemán esta lista se llegue a
esta decisión quizás se crea esta
excepción con hungría de la república
checa y eslovaquia que dependen para
recibir petróleo de pasar por otros
países por lo cual toda la logística es
más compleja pero lo que demuestra esto
es que la decisión de parar a vladimir
putin está llevando a los países
europeos a tomar decisiones que van a
tener un costo muy alto para sus
sociedades pero lo están haciendo porque
lo consideran de que es indispensable
para frenar la máquina de guerra de
vladimir putin y hay cinco países que
son los más dependientes del petróleo
ruso estos son eslovaquia lituania
polonia finlandia y hungría
estos tienen entre el 78 y el 66 por
ciento de su petróleo por parte de rusia
en este sentido como los afectaría a
ellos el embargo y qué opciones tienen
yo creo que todo todo el mercado se está
moviendo el mercado petrolero un mercado
internacional donde cuando faltan
barriles llegan barriles cuando alguien
está pagando más por barriles llegan los
barriles será un tema de una dislocación
temporal del mercado pero a la larga yo
creo que inclusive alemania que no que
como decía anteriormente no tenía la
logística para recibir petróleo por
buques ya lo encontró y le encontró
justamente a través de los puertos de
dance end en polonia decir polonia
simplemente se abrirá a buscar petróleo
de los emiratos árbes petróleo de arabia
saudita petróleo del oeste de áfrica y
yo creo que al final del mercado se va a
adaptar el problema que va a tener rusia
a quien le vende el petróleo rusia y me
imagino que si se lo quiere vender en
los países asiáticos se lo tienen que
vender con un gran descuento eso a su
vez va a contribuir a que el mercado
baje tienes también otro problema en la
guerra va a bajar el crecimiento
económico y el consumo en europa y el
consumo en rusia todos tampoco ahí hay
otro elemento también de compensación
increíblemente el tema mismo de los
precios altos
el crecimiento económico también juega
dentro del arreglo suministro sitio en
un proceso de muchísima demanda y de
altísima demanda sería más difícil pero
como todo el mundo sabe que vamos por un
período de bajo crecimiento y todos los
países están preparados para una
recesión producto de la guerra el
consumo también baja además de obligar a
rusia a buscar conexiones en su petróleo
con asia como golpearía hasta embargo la
economía de rusia
pero la economía rusa está muy golpeada
lo que pasa es que el problema es si a
vladimir putin le importa dentro de lo
que son las opciones de put y que está
muy cerca o no tiene ninguna salida
buena para el perder es perderlo todo
perder la guerra perder el poder
perderle poderes perder la impunidad por
lo tanto la psicología de putin y un
grupo pequeño de gente que está re orden
puede no reaccionar pero en mucha gente
reducción que está siendo impactada por
las sanciones económicas que ha sido
mucho más grande de lo que esperaba y
estas acciones energéticas afectan mucho
a muchísima gente muchísimas empresas y
tiene un efecto en cadena en la economía
rusa que podría pasar de un a un
crecimiento negativo del 10 por ciento a
mucho más grande si se materializa este
embargo